before before you came in you're talking
about how you shut you special would you
say 15 years ago yeah
oh you're talking about my first one
yeah yeah dude that was crazy I was
looking back at you know start time like
save for the podcast yeah I got it I
want people to hear this yeah it's just
I know where it's gonna go but ya know
uh just I remember when I got it it was
I'm talking about my half hour though
yeah forgot the half hour is your first
semester the half hour but yeah that was
my first like that was my first big
thing was my comedy central half hour
then how long we doing comedy before you
got that half hour I was about 15 years
in yeah 15 yeah 15 years in an hour and
I got it and then uh how did you get it
auditioning no um I don't know how I got
that you know I dunno how I got it I got
on stage and uh Doug Herzog saw me where
were you at at the Gibson theatre and I
opened and I were open for I think it
was the Mencia tour oh nice and then I
got offstage and he walked right up to
me he goes have we talked to you about a
special and I go no he goes I'm gonna
give you special and that was Doug hers
I use the president
yeah and that was it I literally got it
from him especially at the time like
commie Central was there Dolby yeah that
was yeah 18 years ago big boy yeah
it was literally I think my son was one
I think I can't remember like so don't
quote me I don't want you guys go
research it who cares about is like
right when my son was like like maybe
two years old so whatever like 14 years
ago and so did you guys first person you
told ah my mom come on mom
uh-huh called her called her and she
didn't give to Fox she was just like
yeah they don't get it
no she don't know what central was he
didn't know what that was you know I
mean and if she was still like are you
still going to be at Wells Fargo like
what the [ __ ] oh no I I'm shooting a
half-hour special like nothing just
Wells Fargo going to be okay with you
calling it like what do you well Fargo
and give you 30 minutes off are they
gonna give you 30 minute in between your
break like on lunch break then go shoot
and then come back is there anything
more frustrating but like nothing tries
to be more nuts when I want someone to
share the
same experience with me and they don't
understand my dad like me I wouldn't
show time started coming day goes yeah
that's cool so in this speech and I have
a bit about now it might be so in your
speech how exactly are you know speed
yeah speech the [ __ ] are you talking
about speech went you've ruined dad yeah
you're ruining everything God dang it
yeah I remember when I got the Tonight
Show I was at Montreal and Omni Festival
yeah I did the Montreal just for laughs
and then I did a new faces and right
when I walked offstage Ross and Bob they
were the Booker's for the Tonight Show
and and Ross mark and Ross walked up to
him they were like save that for the for
The Tonight Show we want that whatever
you did right right there do that save
that we want that on The Tonight Show
and I my heart because I was working at
Nordstrom Rack at the time and I was
just like you know shelving shoes and I
was just like oh [ __ ] it made it oh and
I went called my mom and it was the
[ __ ] worst response the [ __ ] horse
response like just nothing like mom I
got the Tonight Show
oh it's so tonight he'll be on tonight
no I got I booked it all capable when
like well like they'll give me a date
time oh okay well um you know your
auntie is having a birthday this
Saturday and are you going to be able to
wait no we're not sharing the same
excitement dude I'm still on the tonight
I just go to stage nothing just got
booked okay but can you bring maybe okay
or something and I just remember my mom
it's like my family grew up we idolize
Portia's that was the [ __ ] yeah no one
my family had one I bought one this is
years ago I bought one as soon as I got
in the car bluetooth first when I called
my dad my dad goes yeah what's going on
I go you're talking to your son in a 911
career my day goes well year I go brand
new Papa brand new just like we we
talked about he goes yeah my friend has
the turbo yeah well this isn't the turbo
yes yeah those are nice man the turbos
on it we got no again you keep bringing
up the turbot I don't have the turbo
this is just your 911 egos those are
cool
but my friend he just talks about French
trouble I went you know I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go now yeah
you've ruined them over yeah you ruined
everything how about how about when I
call my down my Gert when I found out my
girls pregnant so so my girls super
Mexican right yeah so she calls her
mom's super Mexican by the way is a
Mexican that can save live correct
that's you know Supermax in it yeah not
worry about walls no walls they laugh at
the wall that's you meet Hall ice bring
it yeah Supermax it's a super so uh she
calls when she finds out she's pregnant
I'm out of shooting something for you
see tonight and she's blowing me up I
come home I can what and she goes she
has this little thing says you know
pregnant and she has a sign she's crying
she calls her mom you know Mexican she's
so happen she puts her mom at speaker
she's like mama
we're pregnant her mom's freaking out
just ask me Oh blah blah blah blah oh my
yeah okay cool I go let me call my let
me call my dad yeah watch out for this
ready for this and I call my dad now you
go hey papa and he goes what's up he's
so serious you know
Joanna's pregnant is this is on
speakerphone by the way your phone and
I'm like dismal I'm looking at my girl
Mike and he goes you know you don't have
to keep it oh no no oh and I pretend
with I'm gonna call you back yet and he
hung up my when no I know you're joking
that's so hilarious no I'll tell her
I'll thank you okay have a good day and
my girls like what the [ __ ] i you know
he's joking he's what he's joking he's
joking he ruined that moment too though
that's [ __ ] funny did he really
oh yeah goes do you talk about this on
stage not that well that's a [ __ ]
great one I want your son here's
actually hear what grandpa said the day
he was conceived right her family's fun
you got a pinata already filled with
diapers like Oh what is it a boy or a
girl we just found down I can't wait to
find out you're dead they kill it
destroy it then yeah you still got
better you still got that Navy SEAL dog
feed it to that yeah you're that thing
yeah put your girlfriend's vagina next
to that
dog kids are the worst kids are the
worst you know you were my kid [ __ ]
hated you Helen is my mother
my Ma's get Sheila's the podcast sorry
mom you know it's true though my mom
comes out you can see my son and my sons
like having one of his issues this is
like two years ago he's like one and a
half
he's just having one of those fits or
something like that and my mom's not
used to you know yeah and I go hey shoes
stay in a hotel and I go hey mom so you
want to get lunch a bit the staff my son
France she goes ah I could just as she
does not I don't I don't I don't
I actually don't um strap me off at the
hotel it well we just we just picked you
up she goes I know it's just this whole
kid thing
I just wasn't made to have kids I don't
watch like I went oh my feelings are so
heard of it
oh that's cool yeah I'll truck backed
off the hotel and just was like so and
then she got out like no my girl just
wasn't made advocate so that's cool you
know are you being serious
that's it your mom said that yeah with
your straightest face with the
straightest face just like she's hope
she's laughed at this great sense of
humor not that day about that day well
okay that doesn't make any sense my body
wasn't made to have kids just said I
wasn't meant to have kids oh you two
kids in the car just now more kids it's
not a kid person are your listeners
hearing this your mommy I wasn't
supposed to have you and I sure so fun
so once you're sure it's not gonna be
around this kid this kid [ __ ] no but
that's what you have to deal with you
drop me off why do you listen to your
dad so she says the other car when you
listen to your dad you need to have this
less your dad your son's just sucking on
some iron over there sucking on a
pacifier being cute is no idea he's six
foot tall in us in his car seats LeBron
Jerzy [ __ ] size 11 shoe reed akley what
1/2 years old your death your your son
takes this pacifier this grandma not
like me what's grandma's [ __ ] deal
down [ __ ] the [ __ ] is wrong with Grandma
grandma has her issues ok grandma's fine
she's just yeah well I just went caca
why should my parents again yeah no one
stopped me how so and stop that dad hmm
you don't [ __ ] grandma I'm a [ __ ] man
we should be grandma where's my booby
where's my BB where's my BB Jesus right
what's your son's name
Tiger Tiger of course oh [ __ ] great
why I don't know what it is I don't know
why P I I don't call people I only call
certain people during big moments like
even my brother he's not he's just a
really calm like nothing he's never know
he's never hi it's always that flatline
frequency yeah I get like yo I just I
win the lottery man three hundred
million dollars I would text him and
whatever I text on my K just won the
lottery three hundred million dollars
response even no matter what it is cool
cool cool cool okay sounds good okay
sounds good alright alright alright yeah
so you gotta call certain people you
gotta you gotta decide who you're gonna
call to show you me yeah man but my
hopes for moments I think my mom's [ __ ]
on every moment what's wrong with them I
don't know are they haters I don't know
what it is it's never enough
I just don't yeah I know it's never it's
never nobody's not cool
yeah like what would be cool oh this is
my favorite I go it'd be cool if you
become a senator yeah if you become a
senator John SEP perfect how about my
mom text me because I need to talk to
you I got a great idea I'm like I wonder
what it is I call her this before they
casted someone else that's Batman she
goes you should be the new Batman wait
I'm sorry what are you saying yes you
should be the next Batman you make a
great Batman go yeah no doubt no that's
what you want I what she's out thank you
for that yes thank you they booked Ben
Affleck
for that and I'm not an actor yeah so
that's kind of that's problem there yeah
mom and they just don't give Batman the
guys that I think look like Batman so
you thought great idea yeah mo do you
think I should just walk up and say I'm
Batman and then they'll give it to me
Batman I'm Batman
no harder to get babbit yeah there's an
application mom no mom and also those
guys but like the guys that become
Batman I've been doing it forever
yeah yeah my mom I remember when I first
started my mom my mom was emailing cuz
she doesn't she wasn't now she's savvy
now my mom is on Facebook and stuff but
I'm talking like you know back in the
day my mom would go you know I email you
all the time and you don't respond not
like who do you who you email imam ja
quite calm I'm like okay that's that's
not an email mom come on mom and the
whole time
angry is [ __ ] not answering my tags does
not answer my phone cuz she's mad that
I'm not responding this is something
that's not being sent to me old school
man you're quite calm and I've been
telling everyone to email you at Jo koy
calm all right well good mom that's
thanks for telling them to go to my
website old school man parents are old
school dude breaks your heart right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]